stop
competing on price if you want to have a
long-term
sustainable advantage drive money into
your company
into your wallet then you can't compete
on price
you have to find another way to stand
out and charge a premium
for what you're doing if you want to
have success in the long term as an
entrepreneur
otherwise it's a race to the bottom
you're always competing on thin margins
and you're never going to have success
as a business owner hi i'm evan
carmichael i believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help
and today i'm answering a question from
a youtube viewer
love you guys youtube viewer lac1212iv
whatever that means wrote in hey evan i
have started a service business that is
specialized in window cleaning
it's so hard to get customers i have all
the professional equipment and i do not
charge much what's a good way to get
customers
so first of all you've told me nothing
about your business
you're a window cleaner that's great
there's tons of window cleaners
i don't want you competing on price if
you get customers who are always beating
you down on price
you're going to end up working for
minimum wage or less
it's not going to be worth your time
you're going to get stressed out you're
going to feel defeated
and you're going to think hey you know
what it's better and less stressful to
go out and get a job
you have to find a way to stand out as a
window cleaner
what's wrong with most window cleaning
companies i don't know
you have to tell me what makes you
different why should i hire
you over every other window cleaning
company or over doing it myself
you have to communicate that message you
have to come up with it yourself
know what makes you stand out and it has
to be real it's got to be something that
you feel
you have to get into this business
because you feel that the other winning
cleaning companies
they suck they're all doing it wrong
there's a huge
hole in the marketplace and you're going
to jump in and solve it
if you're just getting into window
cleaning because you think it's an
opportunity to make a quick buck
it's not gonna happen stop now go back
and get a job
you have to love cleaning windows you
have to bring something that nobody else
is doing
and use that in all your messaging what
is different
about your window cleaning company that
people would want to pay a premium for
versus everybody else that's out there
instead of struggling over price and
competing with everybody at the bottom
you have to separate yourself and come
up and it has to be tangible it's got to
be real there has to be something that's
different especially unique about what
you do
and communicate that in every
conversation
with potential customers or anybody who
could potentially help your business
when you wrote to me you wrote just to
say
i have a window cleaning business and i
have professional equipment
that means nothing to me this is your
opportunity to tell guys like me
why you are different what is wrong with
the market
how can you fix it that nobody else can
do it and what's the benefit to me
make me care and if i believe in it
strongly enough
then price will be my last concern and
those are the clients that you want to
get out
and they'll be your best clients they'll
be repeat clients
they'll bring on more business for you
they'll refer their friends to you
and that's the way to build a successful
service based business
i know it's hard i know when you're
first starting up it's hard you want to
get your first customers you're trying
to do everything yourself things are
overwhelming but this is
really really important like this you
have to care about
you have to be in this business for a
reason not just to make money
and maybe you have that reason already
and it's just not coming out and how you
communicate it
but it's so important to have that
message
if you don't you're not going to build a
hugely successful company and i want
that for you i want you to have a
company that you can
hang your hat on and say i built that
i'm proud of what i did you want to go
to work every day feeling great about
what you're doing
so get your messaging down good luck
communicate it to everybody
and you will get more business for those
of you watching you like the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes me want to do more for you
and i want to hear from you what do you
think about this video
leave it in the comment section below i
always read those i really love seeing
those come in
even if you've left a comment before
leave another one it makes my morning
really every time i see them come in
and if you have a question for your own
company i'd love to try to answer it for
you
if you leave in the comment section
below thank you guys see you soon